hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
and book 11 of his City of God Saint
Augustine explores this notion of human
beings having been created after in the
image of God and this has raised a lot
of questions for many people who want to
interpret that passage from Genesis what
does it actually mean to be created in
the image of God does that mean that God
has fingers and a nose and you know hair
and stuff like that and Augustine
rejects anything like that instead he
says that the image of God within us is
in fact an image of the Trinity and he's
going to talk about this in terms of
what you might call basic aspects or
dimensions of our being and one of them
has to do with our very being in itself
he says we exist we have being and not
only do we exist that's one we also know
that we exist we have knowledge however
dim that knowledge may be we have some
self-consciousness we have some grasp on
our own existence I understand that I
exist and that maybe you don't and that
you aren't me and we could go on and on
he doesn't unpack this here but we might
adduce a lot of corollaries from this
about what it is to know our existence
and then he goes further yet and this is
where it becomes most interesting not
only do we exist not only do we know
that we exist we also love we have we
bear an affective relation at the very
core of our being we love our existence
and we also love the knowledge of that
existence and this is similar to how
many Trinitarian you could call them you
know metaphysicians or theologians
have an unpack this notion of the
Trinity you have the father you have the
son generated out of the father who is
in a certain sense the knowledge of the
father and then you have the Holy Spirit
who is the love between the father and
the son but a love that is you know
equally substantial or consubstantial or
however you want to put it and all three
of them are in fact and this is where it
gets a bit mysterious the same being and
you might say the relations within the
being and we're not going to worry about
that at this point because we're more
interested in the human being and the
corollaries for this so this is telling
us about what it is to to have a human
nature to exist to have knowledge of
existence and to love both that
existence and that knowledge now
Augustine goes a little bit further in
this and he says in these three things
no true seeming illusion disturbs us and
then there are some reasons one is that
he says no bodily sense is involved here
it's not disturbing us there's no as he
says representation or image or the
senses involved instead we grasp this as
he's going to say a little bit later on
through a higher sense that is
distinctively human he says there we go
we have another and far superior sense
belonging to the inner person by which
we perceive what things are just and
what unjust just by means of an
intelligible idea unjust by the means of
it right and this is this is the sense
that we're using - you might say make
sense out of what it is that we we are
so we're using a higher faculty and that
faculty now it could be deceived right
but it's not being deceived because of
the senses or some sort of sort of image
could I be deceived about this he brings
up the academics at this point and the
academics were skeptics they were people
who thought that for every position you
had to provide evidence for it if you
couldn't provide evidence or argument
for it then we should suspend belief in
it
and say well we don't really know and in
their view that applied to just about
everything well some of them accepted a
doctrine of probability put that aside
for the moment he says what if you're
deceived well if I am deceived I am I
exist because who's being deceived right
now if when you read this you say wait a
second I thought Descartes came up with
that idea
no actually Augustine talks about it in
the City of God and Descartes knew about
it through Augustine so Descartes is not
completely original in this respect and
he's pointing out that any deception
would be self contradictory if I'm
deceived about my own existence I must
exist in order to be deceived about it
but he goes further then he says there
we go
if I am deceived I am he who is not
cannot be deceived and if I am deceived
by the same token I am and since I am if
I am deceived how am i deceived in
believing that I am how can I be
deceived about having knowledge of my
own existence he says that it's certain
that if I am that I am if I am deceived
so I the person deceived would be even
if I received certainly I'm not deceived
in this knowledge that I am and
consequently neither am i deceived in
notice what he says here knowing that I
know we not only have knowledge of our
own existence we have knowledge of our
knowledge we we know that we know so we
can't be deceived about that either
he goes on further because remember
there is the third thing he says when I
love these two things I add to them a
certain third thing namely my love which
is of an equal moment and I cannot be
deceived in this that I love I know that
I love since in those things which I
love I am not deceived and then somebody
could say well what if you love the
wrong thing what if you love something
that isn't what you think it is like you
love somebody
who turns out to be a spy for a foreign
country right wouldn't that throw you
for a loop and you'd say well yes I'm
deceived about what they are but I'm not
deceived about the fact that I love them
I'm not deceived about the love and when
it comes to being loving towards our own
selves
I'm not deceived about the fact that I
exist I'm equally not deceived about the
fact that I love my own existence I
might love it in somewhat the wrong way
I might be in the dark about certain
aspects of my my being but I still do
know that I love myself and I love the
knowledge that I have of myself even if
sometimes it's quite painful says in
those things which I love I'm not
deceived even if those were false it
would still be true I loved false things
how can I just leave dand prohibited
from loving false things if it were
false that I love them since they are
true and real who doubts that when they
are loved the love of them is true and
real and Augustine goes further than
this in the chapter that immediately
follows that in book eleven and he talks
about plants and animals now they don't
have knowledge in the way that we do and
they don't possess that higher sense he
thinks the way that we do they are
dependent on the sense world or on what
they're able to take in perhaps through
plants through their you know
equivalent to senses the the biological
mechanisms that govern them but they
still do have being and even though they
don't have knowledge in the full sense
of their being they still do love their
being and desire their being they seek
out what is helpful for them and what
conduces to their continuing to exist
and they avoid what is going to be
damaging to them or cause them not to
exist he he goes on and he talks about
men and
in the similar sense we all try to avoid
our our own deaths but he says that
plants and shrubs which have no life as
enables them to shun destruction by
movements we can see they still seek in
their own fashion to conserve their
existence they root themselves more
deeply in the earth so they may draw
nourishment they draw out healthy
branches to the sky and then he goes out
a little bit further going down the
scale metaphysically in a lower state of
being and he says even lifeless bodies
which want not only some sensation but
even life they seek the upper air sink
deep or a balance so that they may
protect their existence in the situation
where they can exist most in accordance
of their nature we might not want to
follow Augustine that far we might see
that as just you know part of the what
it is for them to be that they don't
have any love for their being but he is
saying that this is something that
living beings do have and notice that
it's very important that for Augustine
we in fact love the knowledge of our
existence we want to understand what our
existence is we don't just want to exist
we want to understand things he says how
much human nature loves the knowledge of
its existence how it shrinks from being
deceived will be sufficiently understood
by this fact every person prefers to
grieve in a sane mind rather than to be
glad in madness and he says this is
unique to us this is grand and wonderful
instinct he says some of them have
keener eyesight than ourselves but they
cannot attain the spiritual light with
which our mind is somehow irradiated so
we can form right judgments of things
this doesn't mean of course that we have
it all figured out
that we totally understand our existence
that we love rightly in every case but
this is central to Augustine's
anthropology and what he's providing you
here with is a conception of what is at
the core of human nature understood not
just in terms of our being and our
knowledge but also in terms of
effectivity what it is that we love what
it is that we desire what it is that we
strive after and that makes us what we
are
you